(Singing) Lalalalalalala... Ow ow, my Seamoth
Ho-lo-loly shit
Holy...
(Deep voice) Holy
(still singing) Holy fucking shit I don't
know where I'm going...
(Sing songy robotic voice) Oh hello you bitch...
Oh hello you bitch
*Computer voice: Caution. Passing safe depth.*
*sound of Seamoth bumping into rock*
Goddammit
Can these goddamn fish stop slamming their bodies into the base of my hull?
I need to sur-VIVVVVE the ocean.
And right now I'm not doing a good job of that.
Hup
Dodgin' death cliff
What ares you, uh huh?
Are you important??
There seems to be some sort of roaring going on around here
and I'm not-
'Stasis rifle?' I don't think I have that.
Ow- whoawhoawhoawait
*multiples surprised "whoas"*
Damn you hurt bad, I don't need the 'Terraformer' that bad.
Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
I've been having a bit of trouble.
I am going on an adventure and
this adventure includes...
going out of my Seamoth
and hoping for the best
but probably not having the best
because everything seems to be going awry but...
I need... something.
I need one specific thing actually.
I need...
one last...
part...
of the Cyclops.
I need ONE last piece
because I've gotten the hull fragment,
and I believe I've gotten the bridge fragment
so there's gotta be another component
of the Cyclops that I have not yet received.
So THAT'S going to be my next objective
because they IMPROVED the Cyclops!
I know they did,
and that means there's gotta be more to it
that I need
and I,
I imagine- and this is what I imagine. I'm not 100% certain about it
but I imagine,
that it involves....
a whole lot more...
utility, speed, dynamisism...
attractiveness and just the general aspect of it,
and overall,
it's gonna be better for me!!
It's gonna be my crowning achievement in this...
reinventioning of this game.
But, I need it.
I need it a lot,
I need it very much so,
because I need the Cyclops in general.
So...
I'm coming over here by the ship
because I would imagine...
that if there was anywhere that there would be fragments of something
it would be by the goddamn ship so,
hoping for the best!
Hoping not to die.
At least I'm coming over here in the middle of the day.
Not at night.
Which is what I usually do.
Ooh that-
This!
This right here, this!
This is-
This is a thing!
*gasps*
Nope, it's not. Nevermind. I was wrong.
Heeee-everybody ignore me,
I thought that was a nnnnnn...
Okay, have I already been here?
I think I might have already been here, okay.
So the ship is there.
Wheeee...
Okay.
I guess I might as well solve the radiation problem here
Boopityboop, boop boop boo boop! Boopityboo, boo bee bee bee bee! Beepitybee, boo bee bee bew!
Beepitybee, boo bee bee bee!
Ow, what the- oh, shit! Goddammit, this piece is falling from the ceiling! This is a bit more chaotic than it used to be.
Oh, also, I think I just remembered...
is...
the...
There's something here! There's something scannable in here...
That's imporTANT.
Ooooh, but what? But what? BUT WHAT? BUT WHAAAAT?
BUT WHAAAAAAT?
BUT WHAAAAAAAAT?
Ahhhh!
OHHHHHH!
A 'power efficiency module,' I don't know why that was there.
And, SHE-BANG! Okay, there we go!
"Drive core breach sealed. Radiation dissipating in three days. Trying to download attempt with Aurora..."
Okay.
*Computer voice: Attention. High energy particle containment field...*
*Two computer voices at the same time to where it's unintelligible*
Wait, there was a lot of stuff going-
*Computer voice: ...radiation levels are estimated to return to safe levels in t-minus: three days..."
Yay!
*Computer voice: 10 hours.*
That's good. Okay, so I'll come back in three days, and that means radiation will be fixed, and then hopefully we
can download this black box because maybe they're putting a bit more story because-
There's a reason!
There's a reason...
why...
"Damage...- Aurora blackbox device not found?" OH.
HUH?
Did that say sabotage?
Iiinterest- "87% of the habitable sections of the ship were rendered uninhabitible..." in a time...
Oooooh, 'pressure compensator,' me likey that.
Okay, I'm getting out of here because I just looked it up. Uh, the last piece for the Cyclops is either in the
mountain area,
or the underwater mountains and the underwater islands, the floating islands.
I was actually just there! Umm, but I didn't go... explore it far enough, so I gotta go back there, so.
I will return!
In time...
Wait a minute... ohhhhh wait, I just realized: this 'pressure compensator,' I think- wait hang on. Is this-?
Oh my god, that's a Seamoth one!
OH!
But the depth is only 300 meters now. Okay, so they changed it.
The Seamoth still can't go down- er, the Seamoth now can't go deep,
but I'm willing to bet that the Cyclops can now go like...
super deep, and wh- is what I need to explore the deep, deep caverns
Ooooh, this is getting interesting
Okay, so, SOMEWHERE AROUND HERE-
THERE'S A GODDAMN THING-
What's that dot in the distance?
You guys seeing what I'm seeing?
That is... distinctly... something, what is that?
Oh!
Ohhhhhh...
Ah, okay so this is the floating islands.
So, this would be...
also...
where I need to be for the thing.
What is that?
*sound of Seamoth hull being hit*
OWWWW, FUCK YOU! Whoa god, I'm almost dead--- OHHH goddammit!
These things come out of nowhere!
Fuck you, dude!
I'm in trooouuuble, ohhhh boy
Dammit!
I gotta bail.
I gotta bail because ONE: I've been bitten to death; and TWO: I'm completely out of water
so I need to grab some airsacks on the way back,
and hope for the best! Uh, I'm gonna go for my life pod
But, man! This has been a journey. Man, this is lulu--- LIFE HAS NOT BEEN KIND TO ME!
THE OCEAN HAS NOT BEEN KIND TO ME!
Because the OCEAN is filled with death!
How many times do I need to tell you guys that the ocean is not a friendly place...
No one should go there- in fact, we should PROBABLY BURN IT
BUT EVEN THAT WOULDN'T WORK BECAUSE IT'S FILLED WITH WATER!
And water doesn't burn, I've tried.
It just
doesn't
work.
This is gonna be close. I'm not a hundred percent about this, but I'm gonna try my best..
I'm over back here, okay, this is good, okay.
Whew, I think we're gonna make it. All right.
Wasn't sure how close I was to it. There's no distance marker, but at least I got these things here.
Alright, give me you...
Give me...
you!
I will take yooouuu as weEELLL- LOINK, okay.
So, I got these guys. I got them. I'm gonna go back up to my life raft, good old life poddy
I actually have a welder, so I can repair this.
Let me do that.
Let me do this.
Hup puh deeeee upppp a deeeeee! Upppp a deeeeee! Duh duh dit the bah, boing!
WHOOOO!!
Take this,  thank you.
Haboi- OHHHH I had a first aid kit?
*Robotic voice: This is an automated distress signal from Aurora Lifepod 17. Co-ordinates attached.*
*Robotic voice: (unknown static) Please send immediate emergency relief team.*
Whoa.
Wait, pod seventeen? Wait a minute.
I'm only pod five.
They said something about coordinated, uhhh, coordinates attached?
That means someone had to be alive to do that! Wait,  whoa whoa whoa.
*Communications Relay robotic voice: Playing message.*
"Goal underscore holy dive-" What the fuck was that?!?
What does that mean?!?
I don't know what that meant, but that was weird
Okay... 'Terraformer-'
I don't need the god damn t- whooooooooa I see something over there!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
I- goddammit, biters.
OHHHH YEEEESSSS!
YES YES YES YES YES YES YES!
YEESS!
YEEEES!
YEEESSS!
YUS YES YES YEEEESSSS!
Ah, it's good, okay.
Good, good, good, good
I got one!
I got one of them
I found one!
Now I need to find two more.
So long as I can find two more I'll be-
A-okaaay.
And the only question is: do I go down for them or do I try to stay a little bit up?
Not a hundred percent sure about this.
At least I've got this depth module; that really did save my bacon.
Ooooh, there's something over there
That'll probably be a good place to start...
Ehhhh, it's gonna be just a hair too deep for me to get to....
Euuugh, there's a lot of magnetite down here
Ah shit, no, up, up, up, up, up
Uhhh, do I see...? Ah shit.
No hull damage, please.
Do I see anything worth going down there by hand?
Mmmmaybe we'll see, alright. Let me go down there.
I can- I can put on my 'pressure regulator' this time-
No no no no no no
Put on my 'rebreather'
'Cause we are of the proper depth for that sort of stuff, and hopefully that's gonna make sure that my air lasts longer.
Okay, do you see anything? Anything? Anything? Come on, come on. Gimme gimme gimme gimme. Gimme fuel
YES!
That's what I was looking for! That's what I was looking for, baby!
That's what I was looking for.
THAT'S what I was looking for!
YES
Gimme one more. Gimme one more. One more, baby. OH I think I see it! YEEESSS!
(extremely high pitched) YEEEES!
OHHHH YEEEAAAAH BABY!
Oh yeah baby!
Ohh yeah baby!!
Ohhh yeah baby!!!
Ohhhh
It even unlocked the 'Cyclops pressure compensator,' I don't even have to go get that any more, that's awesome!
Ohhhh that's awesome
I love that, I love that, I LOVE THAT, I LOVE THAT, I LOVE THAT!
YEESS I'M OUT OF HERE, BABY!
BACK HOOOMMME WE GOT SOME NAMES TO PUT ON THE LOCKERS!!
*Sigh of Relief* It's gonna be a good day.
It's gonna be a good day.
Helloooo, helloooooo, hello, hello, hi, hi, hi.
I'm not gonna park it in the Moonpool yet because I don't want it to drain my entire base of power and turn it into a
goddamn horror movie.
But we got it!
We got it!!
Oh man, did we get it, okay.
(quietly) What's that? Oh, uranium.
So...
We have...
a...
Cyyyyy... *yawn*
YCLOPS
So we need plasteel ingot, enameled glass, lubricant, and advanced wiring kit. Now that may seem like a LOT...
The only thing that I'm worried about is the enameled glass, but I actually have two teeth already...
So, this is not gonna be that big of a deal because plasteel needs lithium,
but I have an ample supply of lithium already. So I just need the titanium ingots, I need to get more lubricant,
the advanced wiring kit, obviously. But...
everything is in working order and we have it. So I'm gonna go get those things,
then I'll be good.
Oh, boy
Shebede shab bob bob do yea ba da ba- THERE ARE YOU, GIMME SOME BIIIITE!
Bite my butt!
Bite my *deep* butt.
Doooooo
Oh no...
Did you hurt yourself?
Did you lose a tooth?
PROBABLY.
GIMME MORE! Gimme fuel, gimme fire, gimme that which- did you drop one?
I can't see shit.
*Old man voice* GIMME YOUR TEETH! *Fart Sound*
Sorry, did you die?
I'll just steal it from your corpse after you're gone.
Where is it? Where are you? Where are you? I know I gotcha. I know, I-
There we go. Okay two Stalker teeth
Uhhhh, five glass. Alright, so that should be enough
Enameled glass- YEAAAAH WE GOT IT, BABY!
Of course we got it, why else wouldn't we got it, why would we not got it?
WE GOT IT!
BLAAAAAHYAYAYAYAYA...
(tired?) OKAY, we got enameled glass, we got plasteel ingot, we just need advanced wiring kit
and lubricant- goddammit, ugh.
It's taking forever.
Okay, while I'm here, I will read the new names on the lockers
because I forgot to do it in the beginning of this video.
Thank you to Jake Moor, Oliver Pitcher, and Richard Aaron Aruda Nerpio.
All of who I put as R.A.A.N on my things for all commenting.
Thank you all so much! Uh, Jake said this was one of his favorite series. And then Oliver said if you close your
eyes, for most of any episode that I play... it sounds like an orgy.
A one-man orgy.
And then Richard Aaron Aruda Nerpio doesn't even know how to swim.
So, thank you guys so much.
I got to go get stuff.
BRB
AHHHH NIGHT TIME!
Alright, this will be the last one and...
computer chip, and then, badabing badaboom, advanced-
BOINK!
OKAAAY!!
ALRIGHT, WE DID IT!
Oh my god, that took forever.
Okay, we got it. Okay, we got one, two, three, four, five; one, two, three, four, five; one, two, three, four, five
And then, advanced wiring kit, right there. WE ARE GOOOOD. WE'RE- ow.
Okay.
So,
This is it, this is the moment we've all been waiting for.
Where's Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall? I know they're up here somewhere.
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall.
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall?!?
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall?
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, Marshall?
Uh-oh.
Well.
Uhhh...
Ah, there you are!
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall.
I've got a job for youuu!
I know it's the middle of the night, but
frankly, this is kind of important.
Hup!
Alright.
Boink!
BOINK!
(very incomprehensible Mark noises)
OHHHHHH
YEEEESSS!
YESSSS!
That is awesome.
You boys are amazing; I love you all!
Oh and it's the breaking of a new dawn.
I couldn't ask for a more perfect moment for this Cyclops to be birthed.
And,
AHHHHHH
BLEUGHAH!
Ohohohohohohoho yeeaah!
Thank you boys!
Thank you boys, very kindly.
Well...
I'm about to board my Cyclops.
Hello, baby!
How are you doing?
*Male Robotic Voice: Welcome aboard, captain. All systems online.*
Whoa.
Heeey!
And I've got new lockers!
Oh, but I can't- I can't change the names on those, oh- this is....
This is cool. They updated this, didn't they?
This looks way cooler.
Ooooh, it's got upgrade modules.
It's only got four upgrade modules possible, but I've already got one on my person.
'Power efficiency,' which is good.
Power efficiency now four hundred percent, which is very, very good.
OHHHH LOOOK. Lighting?
Ahhh...OHHHH
*gasps*
I can save power!
OHHHHHH!
Oh nooo!
HUOOOOH!
I don't know what to name it.
Ohhhh, I don't know what to name it.
Ahhhh, it's gotta be something new.
AHHHHHH.
I will leave this up to you guys.
You guys tell me what you want to name this brand new Cyclops, and then I'll take it out for a spin
I love the fact that I can turn off and on the lighting
That is...
AWESOME.
That is so cool.
I love the moodiness, it's so spoopy in here.
Ohhh, that's cool.
But either way,
this is- I've been working really hard in this episode.
It's been a long one for me, maybe not long for you guys, but it's been a long one for me, so,
THANK YOU EVERYBODY SO MUCH FOR WATCHING!
Let me know what you want to name this brand new ship
I will name this AND the Seamoth in the next episode, so.
Thank you again, and as always
I will see you...
...in the next video.
Bye-bye!
(first video) I'm gonna vacuum up
HONEEEEEEEEY
HONEEEEEEY
WERE YOU WATCHING SOMETHING IN THERE?!?
(second video) *Other Music Starts and Becomes Layered On Top of Outro Music*
*Clapping and Hi-hats*